you bought an existing Pub that was
running as a pup how much you pay for it
310 and you got planning to do what to
it to change it into a fully embed HMR
do you know what value is now 1.2
million now the value is what we're
going to get valued at the reason I have
a value that matters what's your monthly
cash flow now 10 85 pounds so that was a
400 000 pound build but we was quoted a
million pounds from Builders and then we
refinanced at 1.1 million so effectively
got all our money out with a bit of cash
left over we paid 210 for a free bed
Terrace we sold it with 385 in the same
year do you know what your portfolio is
valued at right now today 3 million and
fifty thousand
so Hudson holiday welcome to winners on
a Wednesday over the last few years
you've absolutely exponentially seen a
lot of growth in your in your property
portfolio how did you get into property
in the first place what made you get
into property and how did this Empire
start we just decided to get into it to
build something together so the Harley
didn't actually have to work for anybody
else
he works for himself from day one he's
never been employed and we're building
our own portfolio to you know create
generational wealth and you guys are
brothers Brothers yeah so what's your
background then so my background was I
done mixed martial arts up until I was
about
17. so I had like over 100 amateur
fights and I was gonna go down that path
and then I decided to go to university
so I went and studied business and
management at University and then when I
was coming like about Midway through
that course that's when we decided to go
into property so I'm finishing
University I went straight into the
business and decided to grow that rather
than going to the corporate world and at
the time you had a construction company
is that right yeah I've always had an
engineering company for about 10 years
yeah smart background is in construction
and others to do property but I needed
some more time so I decided that I had
somebody to get going we'd done some
training we got ourselves moving and
then hardly had unlimited time because
it was his job then to build our
business but he was doing in his own
terms I love the way you've kind of
brought your skills together as well you
know you had a bit of time you just
finished University you had a bit of
money from your from your engineering
business yeah taught me through the
first deal then I believe that was in
about what five years ago now yeah it
was 2018. yeah so we went up to do a
business meeting up in Blackburn so we
thought we'd look at some houses up
there at the same time we viewed 13
houses ended up buying a little two bed
by to let for 42 000. so I buy cash for
that then we lived up there for a month
where they went through just on fishing
beds in the house rips it all out
really just the hard way hardly learned
a lot on that job because his first
build job learn how to fit kitchens
bathrooms and then from then on we just
built it and expanded it so that was a
baby stepping stone and you bought it
for 42 Grand yeah did you have to pay
stamp Duty or was it uninhabitable no we
did pay stamp Duty a tiny bit I was
going to say yeah
so it was a tiny bit tiny bit of stat so
what talk me through the figures then on
that deal if you if you remember them
five years later so you bought it for 42
how much did you spend doing it up I
know you did some of the works yourself
so we only spent ten thousand doing it
up so that included all the expenses as
well driving from Kent to Blackburn yeah
so the actual spend was about 6 000 on
it so that was labor and material so
like shopping Roundup B and Q get in the
kitchen for 800 quid yeah because it was
on sale yeah and bringing it all
together that was amazing that you can
refurb a house when you're on it and
your project managing it yourself how
cheap you can actually do a Reverb for
like a full refurb for 10 grand that's
Madness Labor's free so yeah because you
do it yourself yeah that's the kicker
when you get a building that's when the
costs come up and everyone starts paying
Mega Money for you know what's is a
small job do you manage all your own
projects yourself yes yeah I guess that
really helps with brr because the whole
point of biofurmacy finances you want to
buy it as cheap as you can you want to
get the refurb done obviously to a good
standard but as cheap as possible and
then you want to get that end valuation
as high as possible and the refurb is
where a lot of people do it just it just
runs away doesn't it the thing is when
you imagine yourself you've got 20 30 40
buffer yeah so you can have a really
high-end finish and you can pay the
money at the end because you've saved it
the whole way through yeah so you can
get a lot of problems yourself have you
still got that property today do you
still own it yeah what's it worth now
about 75 000. cool and you refinanced it
so we really find it straight away so we
got it valued at 68 straight after the
works and then after that we've just
left it now so one when we do refinance
it we don't take any more money out we
just get a new mortgage product is that
kind of what you've done is your
strategy being you obviously had a
little bit of money to begin with from
you from working hard as yeah on your
engineering company is that what you're
doing if you just sort of recycle them
money again and again and again yeah
we've essentially grown from that part
I've continued to put in bits for the
early stages but we're at a stage now
where the property company outstrips
what we could put in right so we're now
into the Realms of investors and Banks
and bigger yeah bigger projects every
project now is around a million pounds
and you've done how many projects have
you done in the last few years since you
since that first one so we've done seven
projects and we've kept five of them
yeah and sold off too yeah and what's
your monthly cash flow now from the
property from the property business so
their property business cash flows 24
000 would you start over 24 190 but
that's totally passive
um and that's that's Revenue turnover or
that's actual profit no that's revenue
revenue turnover sure and then what
about how much are you left with after
you've paid all your 10 885 pounds you
know the exact number I like it I
remember when you came to the
accelerator performance program
um when you sort of finished with all
the Academy training and you had this
big thick do you remember yeah tell us
what happened and we bought a basically
a guy side of what we do and how we did
it yeah and telling our story from day
one to where we're going to end up and
just had it all in black and white so
you knew where we was so we discuss
things you can see it I did I remember
seeing all these addresses yeah when you
showed me and I thought that it was
stuff in the pipeline but you're like no
no we refinanced that one we did that
one and I was I was shocked at how much
because when you're going through the
academy you guys you're quite quiet kind
of keep your heads down you know you've
come to the training and stuff like that
but you weren't like up and speaking and
super vocal yeah you just cracked on and
you were quietly just buying refurbing
refinancing
um and and you've built you know really
really good sales portfolio now so um
what would you say has been the key to
your success of being able to scale to
the to the extent that you're having the
time that you have I'll say the the
self-management and motivation
at no point if we stopped yeah we didn't
get a deal anything right we'll do this
we'll get to find another one we've
always had a problem with building and
then through the dead periods we've gone
out actively looking and now we've got
people just ringing us saying that we've
got HMR valuable it's 24 bases you want
to buy it well yes you know so we're now
bringing the work to us as opposed to
finding it what has been your most
exciting project the one that you're
most proud of probably the Wellington
because it was our first large HMO so
it's a 14 bed former Pub slash Hotel
pretty bad standards um need a complete
gun so the only thing we kept is just
the four walls so that was a 400 000
pound build but we was quoted a million
pounds from Builders and we brought in
for 400 so that's probably the one that
I'm most proud of so talk with the
figures on that one then we purchased it
at 310 we spent 400 on it we've got
obviously the cost of purchase and
finance and then we refinanced at 1.1
million so effectively got all our money
out with a bit of cash left over to go
into the next deal and that's a HMR yeah
in bed and how much does that bring in
um per month so it brings in 9 800 a
month damn so that's like almost half of
your revenue is coming from one deal
yeah so we've doubled up now on that so
the numbers have gone up by another nine
thousand now nine and a half Grand
because we've got a 16 bed we've just
finished we just go for a refinance on
that in the next couple of months
where's your patch have you got one area
or are you just buying all over so
predominantly we're based in Sheffield
yeah so the large majority of the
portfolio is in Sheffield but you're
based in Kent yeah how did you come
about finding your package in Sheffield
how did that happen we basically started
to use research on various towns and
cities and it's the most populated
fastest growing city that's on the quiet
so it's not Manchester birming or London
it's the fourth biggest city in the UK
and not many people realize that
population wise they've all got to live
somewhere there's plenty of students
there there's loads of professionals
there and there's a lot of growth when
we first went there wasn't two cranes in
the city now there's 20 cranes every day
if you look across the city now this
Tower is going up everywhere
so it's the place to be and we've seen
house prices we've done a couple of
flips we paid 210 for a free bed Terrace
we sold it for 385 in the same year
um so the Finish is what gets you the
money ultimately but the right areas
yeah there's two areas in Sheffield that
you wouldn't want to buy the houses in
but in the right postcodes on the right
roads if you know where they are you can
smash it do you know what your portfolio
is valued at right now today yeah three
million and fifty thousand wow and when
you started off yeah starting I thought
42 Grand Place and now it's a three
million pound property portfolio yeah
effectively with you know if you lived a
normal life you wouldn't have to work so
well yeah absolutely I mean making over
ten thousand pounds profit a month from
a portfolio which is snowballing up in
value I mean it's it's it's
life-changing stuff yeah like say every
deal that we do now we want to try and
get a million pounds per deal so million
pounds profit no million pound per deal
so each deal with each of my end value
would it be around a million pounds or
more so we're not like we're no longer
doing four five six bets because they're
just not stacking up in the market so
and also it makes sense because you know
I always say don't don't grow this way
grow this way because if you end up with
100 houses all over the place you've got
100 boilers 100 families but if you can
start doing bigger deals it takes just
as much effort to do a big deal on a
small deal really well this is it's the
same paperwork yeah it's just bigger
numbers and especially with the
maintenance now we've had a few issues a
little bit of painting required when you
send them out to a 14 bed HMO when
you're paying the Builder for a day you
split that between 14 rooms whereas if
that's a little four bed he's still
gotta go out for a day and you've only
got four rooms to split against yeah so
effectively that month wasn't worth
running whereas on the 14 bed we could
have a builder out a few days a month
and it still still is worth having it
there how do you manage the projects
then if you're based in Kent and you've
got properties mostly in Sheffield how
do you project manage it from from that
distance so I stay on site right so and
up until the latest projects I spent the
first two weeks there and then I managed
it going up and down so it's just simple
I wake up three o'clock in the morning
travel up there and travel back the same
day or stay over that night the Market's
changed a lot the last couple years what
was the year when we met and you came to
the property versus crash course it was
a year ago about a year ago 2022. okay
so even even in the last year though
like the Market's changed a lot a year
ago if you go to estate agents and you'd
say I'm looking for a cheap rundown
property that I can buy and push the
value up they'd be like join the queue
and things were selling like hotcakes
yep whereas now it's more of a buyer's
market and you can get properties a lot
cheaper but at the same time interest
rates are higher
um you know properties might not be
worth as much at the end value so you
need to be conservative with the with
the refinance so what what have you
found have you found the market have
changed and how has that affected your
strategy and your approach I think
Everything's Relative in terms of it
doesn't matter when you buy when you
sell it is what it is you can't change
it but what we have found is that when
we're going to get a deal they always
want top dollar they always want to put
the prices up because we show the
interest to purchase it as developers as
landlords they're like it must be worth
it then you know they're looking at us
rather than us having to sort of haggle
over a price it's more okay saying look
it's worth this it's a take it I'll
leave it deal so we don't go and look at
the price anymore we look at what the
building is what it's worth to us make
an offer right yeah so you just work
your numbers backwards yeah yeah end
value is going to be x minus the refurb
cost minus our profits yeah this is what
we can buy it for who cares what the
asking price is who cares what the value
is today this is the price I can pay the
value is what we're going to get valued
at yeah you know there is another value
that that matters if you could say it's
worth a million if I can only value at
900 it's never worth anything to me yeah
you know but we had one the other week
that was uh 49 bed HMO of course two
buildings they were three million pounds
okay cash flow works out fine but the
place was a wreck so when you factor in
a refurb empty them for probably a year
it doesn't work you know the costs have
to reflect what he's doing yeah you know
the cash flow works and this is why the
big hmos need to maintain them
ridiculously because after four or five
six years the cash flow's still there
and you'll still keep it but it's not
advertisable people don't want to live
there you know and when you purchase
them there's no profit because you're
buying the market value right so we have
to buy you know as if it's not been
refurbed what do you think people's
biggest mistakes is when going about the
the strategy when trying to buy houses
do them up what do you think the common
mistakes that you see people doing all
the time are it's definitely spending
too much money to begin with and then
it's employing the wrong Builder
so like a lot of people they buy a house
they think they can give it to a builder
and turn back up when their job's done
yeah that's not how it goes like you can
go on the weekend to check on your
Builder you can go up there have a look
at the job but if you don't see it
through the stages and just wait till
the end as soon as it is finished it
might look nice but behind the scenes is
what's going to cost you money so if all
the plumbing isn't done correctly
electrics especially with hmos because a
lot of Builders don't know older eggs
right so where we organize it and bring
all the guys in I'll give them a list of
all the jobs that needs to be done but
that's in correlation with the
regulations yeah whereas like when you
just put a normal builder in and say
right I want a HMO you're expecting them
to go and have to do all the research
exactly on all the requirements to fire
doors there's something quite a time and
if a builder does knowledge them
requirements he's going to charge you
for it so the deal might not snap right
that's so true and a lot of people
well just say to a builder how much to
refurb this property yeah and it's like
well what are you talking about what
does that even mean you need to be
really specific about what you want how
you want it done the spec and as you say
if it is a HMO you need to know it
doesn't need an emergency light it
doesn't need fire doors does it the
Builder the build doesn't know no
nothing you need to know yeah one of the
biggest things we have found is that if
you do provide all the detail the quote
will come back horrendously higher so
delivering it yourself and bringing
trades like trades within organically so
you bring a plumber and you bring
electricians in and you build your own
team on the site it's the best way of
doing it financially yeah yeah whether
you've got time or not you know if you
give it up your time you'll save the
money yeah so if you don't give up your
time you have to pay the money yeah it's
just you know this is simple really yeah
or partner with somebody that and I know
this is one of the things that I've been
getting you to do which is to get
investors on board that this is I've got
a bit of money yeah and and and and
collaborate with people that know what
they're doing and know how to do it this
is it I mean the biggest thing is
getting into the next level of investors
so away from people's personal money and
getting into pots of money and funds
there they've got a goal they need to
hit targets and it's a straight up
business it's not a transaction between
two people anymore it's a complete
company yeah so that's the road we want
to get to what did you think when you
when you came to the crash course and
you saw because obviously you you've got
a background in construction you're
doing your property business what sort
of changed in your sort of strategy and
approach in the last year or so we never
actually come to the crash course
originally we just signed up we just
come straight to your house and had the
chat you were just like I know I'm in it
was just a case of it's the next stage
in our progression yeah so we joined for
one percent if we got one percent the
value out of it was worth doing right
you know because it's not about learning
everything we're already in the trade
we're already doing it we're all getting
free fights getting all our cash out
every time it's a case of what is the
one percent we can pick up from you that
you do that we don't right and that's
the difference and what was what was the
one percent or hopefully more than one
sent well a big part for me with the
market so on the accelerator you know
training yeah it was the market and it
was Bank simple straight to the point
and that's what we come for was the
answers
understanding how to what like raise
Finance get yourself out there be seen
more of the brands inside okay so
actually like creating the brand yeah so
a lot of the time it's always just been
us yeah we're doing this and let them
know about it but we never like you say
we've been quite reserved and we haven't
stood up and said right we know HMO is
inside out yeah probably more than most
people because we're just going about
our business and growing naturally and
organically definitely increasing The
Branding and then since the course we
actually have taken on a rent to rent so
we took on an essay
um it's only been live for a month so
the figures but it should be expected to
make around a thousand at least every
month but that actually takes a little
bit of time to manage whereas the
portfolio is actually it's with a
letting agent so there isn't any
management time with that now yeah
what's been the biggest challenge over
the last few years I would say it's the
opposite to what you have so if we've
got the money we haven't got the deal
and if we've got the deal then we've got
to go and find the money and that was it
when you're looking for something that's
never there and then when you're just
getting about your business you find the
deals the money will come but you don't
know where it's going to come from
necessarily yeah what you found his
obviously like people come to us and say
look I've got some money was like fine
keep on the back burner we know where
they are and then when the deals come
through we could then stack them up and
get the deals done having our own money
he's always been the kicker yeah you
know because we've got our money and
then we've replaced our money with
investors money so our money's still in
the party still circulating so that
every time we go to the investor if they
do yeah only Fall Away we've still got
our own money to complete the deals yeah
so it's we never failed to complete it's
so much easier to raise money when
you've got a bit of money yourself I
mean when I when I started out in
property it's like 17 18 19 buying
houses oh it was really hard and every
time I'd ask the bank for a loan they'd
be like now you alone but then as soon
as I became wealthy like now I've got
money
I can't go into the bank without them
saying would you like a loan yeah I'm
like where were you 12 13 years ago and
I think that we do the same we keep a
bit of money and then every time we need
to raise money it's easy because we can
say look we could raise it ourselves we
wanted to we want to give you an
opportunity to have a share of the deal
and there's only so many deals we can
Finance ourselves and you're coming from
a position of abundance rather than
desperation but what would you say if
you were starting again from scratch and
you had no money see I'm pretty
confident that with you that your
knowledge
and the network that you've got and
you've got a nice big Network now you're
on the academy as well which is which
has been great and it's a massive part
of I believe net worth is also Network
who you know but if you're starting
again from scratch and you had no money
but you had your experience and you had
your network
what would the first steps you would be
to go and start again to build your
portfolio earlier
if I had zero money I do rent or into sa
yeah I would and I love it all
systemized and managed out
and that's the one thing I've sort of
probably got from the academy that I
wouldn't have had before because I
wasn't looking at it so it's not
necessarily something that I'm gonna go
down that road of doing all the time but
we have started just so that we have got
the experience we've got the set up if
the deal comes along you can drop in the
portfolio but if I start again I go down
that road for cash flow yeah what why
would you choose that strategy it's fast
cash cash in the bank and once you're
getting 20 30 grand a month you don't
need two three 400 Grand in the bank
because you can attract that but without
zero coming in you can't be out there
attracting the money
um so I'd say that plus the marketing
yeah be where I'd start I think that
makes sense what about yourself I think
I'd definitely start with deal selling
okay interesting just because I feel
then you aren't open yourself up to any
risk either no so I'll try and make
myself as valuable middleman as I could
so I would go into the networks where
the investors are find the deals even if
I just give away like a few away for
free at first if you can create value
yeah you can charge yeah whereas if I
took on a rent to rent and you didn't
have no money then if it didn't do too
well then you are financially liable
whereas if you're just selling the deal
and once you've sold two or three then
you've got enough money to then be able
to do an essay yeah so I definitely
start with dill selling and then move
into rent to rent and save the funds and
then do BR yeah I think by reference you
finance like what you're doing that will
build a lot of wealth you've got now a
three million pound portfolio it's
bringing in revenue of over 20 grand a
month
but it is quite slow because it's very
slow just to complete on a deal it's
gonna take you six months every Deal's
12 months from the minute you start
buying it to when you get a refinance
it's a minimum of 12 months right yeah
unless it's a tiny deal and we've just
done 16 bed HMR in nine weeks so from
keys to completion is nine weeks for the
build we've now got tenants in it will
be at least another three months before
we get a refinance so nine weeks plus
three months as a minimum yeah you know
and that's plus we had a two-year
purchase on that as well so it took we
it first come about two years ago and
then probably six months ago is when we
actually got the price agreed
so I took 18 months to agree the price
it happens it started super high yeah
and it was just a case of our number was
where we thought it was worth and I we
only ended up 50 Grand above where we
started and they had to come down
several hundreds of thousand yeah but it
was just them accepting it so they left
it on the market and no one brought it
and in the end we was the only people
left so they phoned us up and said that
all right you can have it for this
figure that's the thing about being a
patient investor you've got to be
patient I think when it comes to
investing in property there isn't
hundreds of large deals so that's like a
16 bed it was already in HMI but it was
very tired so it required probably for
most people 150 to 200 Grand spending on
it for us we brought in for 95. so it
wasn't bad brilliant someone said to me
yesterday I've got this deal and it's
taking forever what would you recommend
I do and I said I'd recommend you leave
it in your pipeline
and go and get another deal you've got
to fill your pipeline because if you're
just waiting for one deal to complete oh
it's taking forever and all you focused
on that you might be waiting a year if
you do if you're doing if you're buying
properties what you need to do is you
need to fill your pipeline so you think
if everything all came off at once I'd
actually be screwed so if something
falls through you go thank God that fell
through when you've got a full pipeline
of loads of deals
um then you can afford to be patient and
when I say be impatient I'm not talking
about not taking action be patient but
then when the opportunity comes 10
pounds and be ready yeah I think with
the bigger Deals they tend to Fall Away
more on the small deals anyway yeah so
you do need a couple of big deals always
in the offering yeah yeah you know we've
had two or three Fall Away in the last
two years which were great deals they
fall away for various reasons but
generally it's because the paperwork
isn't right behind the scenes yeah yo
bad leases planning wasn't there they
should have been stuff like that stuff
is going to take a year to get resolved
and the other side is not willing to
meet you halfway on resolving it so
that's the nature of the big stuff
because they're selling for a reason
yeah are you getting commercial
valuations on some of the properties are
you getting bricks
commercial yeah so how do you with HMO
what what qualifiers a HMO property to
be a commercial HMO versus a bricks and
mortar HMR so essentially it's a
standalone HMO it's not a house okay
anything that's the house or could be
used as a house will not get a
commercial value right seven ensuite
bedrooms is perfect yeah six with on
Suites I've heard getting done but it
happens it's not as common if it's got
you so generous planning then all the
way you're getting commercial so seven
bedrooms with ensuite rooms and you're
pretty much okay generally yeah to get a
commercial in article four if you can so
the latest one we just did is within
article four so I might look like you
can't do HMO you can't get them now you
can as long as the houses aren't around
don't exceed 20 so we look for the
pockets and we get the map and we make
sure the surrounding houses there aren't
more than 20 as hmos interesting so a
lot of people just avoid article four
yeah the competition decreases right but
if it's less than seven a lot of the
times they use a hybrid valuation so in
between commercial bricks and more yeah
so you aren't completely down on Brooks
and mortar but it isn't as good as
commercial so Article 4 you're right A
lot of people avoid article four just
what it what is it what does article
four mean it's just a set point from the
Council on the map where you cannot get
more hmos than what they'll allow so if
it's Article 4 it means you can't just
buy a house
rent it out room by room and turn it
into a HMO unless you get planning
permission yes and we know that
generally speaking if an area is article
four they've probably made it article
for a reason because they don't want
more hmos so if it's not always but if
it's Article 4 generally people will go
ah it's article four forget it but what
you do is the opposite you go ah it's
article four like Sheffield is article
yeah right yeah so you'll go I think
only the hammock before I think it was a
few years ago wasn't it you might know
it was before our time it's been there
at least five years okay I remember
going to Sheffield that's why I did my
First Financial Freedom challenge see
and when I went I think it just come in
which to be fair yeah that was November
2018 so I think it just come in but but
if an area is article four no one's
going there to do hmos but what you're
saying is if there's not too many hmos
and there's a ratio then you know that
you'll likely get planning how do you
find that information where did you get
that from well initially we saw on the
HMO register on the council we used to
pin it on the wall on the big map that
we printed out in the office yeah but
now with AI you can just download a heat
map and you can see well I hate the hmos
are saturated in the cities and then put
that onto an actual map and then you can
see whether it's blue you've got a good
chance and you can work it out from
there so you can actually concentrate on
the areas that haven't got many hmos
inside the area rather than the red
zones which are saturated right so
interesting we've made it work once on
one of the deals how long did it take to
get plan permission standard six months
right it wasn't the hard deal because we
had the evidence yeah yeah the hardest
planning was probably the pub because we
had the pub Association got against the
sand you can't take a pub away when all
the locals rejected against it but they
didn't even know what was going to
produce so they were saying that they
didn't want slums and all like that and
now there's a neighbor two doors down
that's actually coming and seen it and
it's got nothing but positive to say now
around the community how long has the
pub been empty when you took it on it
wasn't empty
we were staying there oh so we were
staying there no wonder you found that
trigger damn because I know if it's been
empty for a long time then it's usually
foreign
but it was losing money so it was
unviable for the owners keep running
yeah so if we didn't buy the property of
him then he would have gone bankrupt how
much you pay for it 310 and where was
that in Sheffield yeah so you bought the
pup for 310 how long did it take to get
planning took about nine months that one
and you got planning to do what to it to
change it into a 14 bed HMR oh nice and
he had overall from the neighbors yeah
we made paper as well
that's not the first time the wrong
reasons probably Yeah just they just
slapped you in the paper and shame
greedy developers trying to turn this
into a slum HMO yeah and you still
managed to get planted yeah we've got a
planning consultant on board that used
to work in planning yeah a couple of our
architect that was really good and they
got their photos all the rejections but
did you have to
um appeal or did you get it through
straight away basically we just had to
give the council an extended period of
time because they come back and said no
we aren't ready to make a decision yet
we need more time yeah the architect
turned around and told us well you could
even force them in a decision which they
could say no or you give them more time
and they just come up with a few more
questions so they said rather than like
say no and send it to the appeal stage
answer these questions so we answered
them questions had to do a viability
report on why the pub couldn't run no
more after we submitted all of that then
they said yes I think Planet getting
employment wishes it's a game isn't it
really it's about understanding the
politics understanding the game of it
having a really good planning consultant
and again you know when you talked
earlier about how people just think Bill
doesn't know everything I've not
sometimes people think that people just
know about planning permission as well
they'll be like oh okay the Builder will
be like you should be to get planning
and the builders haven't got a clue
about planning permission even The
Architects often don't know much about
you need to get an actual when you're
dealing with stuff like this an actual
planning consultant that knows got
connections to the council knows knows
the score 100 times the game that's the
keys have local knowledge as well yeah
having a planning for someone that's not
in the city it's not going to work for
you right yeah but I mean at the moment
the hotel's been done for a couple of
years now after the five-year mortgage
period we're going to re-bridge it and
we're going to build another one at the
back beautiful so yeah so how much do
you have to spend on it then turning it
into a 40-bit hm after you've got
planning so 400 000. damn it was
slightly under but it was so you bought
it for 310 you spent just under 400 so
you took about 700 in total do you know
what the value is now 1.2 million now
because it's so events there's only
valued at 1.1 at the time but the rents
have gone up it's about half a million
on that do you know how much you've made
in equity over the five years do you
know what you've it's about 850 000 now
just shy of a million pound Equity yeah
incredible how does it feel do you ever
pinch yourself when you're looking at
the list that you showed me of all the
properties that you've got and the
values do you ever pinch yourself I
think damn wow that's quite impressive
going forward now is going to be a case
of you've done really well in the
periods we've been going I think as we
look to go and do other stuff going
forward that it's going to be like
looking back going well that was amazing
it was amazing five years what's the
strongest reason what's the where does
the fire come from you guys work
extremely hard you know I know you go
and live in Sheffield while there's
refurbs going on
um your proper graft us as well as yes
you've got the education the knowledge
you've got sharp minds but you also work
extremely hard where does that work
ethic and that fire in the belly come
from often from where I grew up so I'm
never going to be poor again so I went
for a period when I left school to other
and got my job I was poor having the job
then I was going to school
so I'm never gonna go back to that I
think that's my drive and my incentive
and now I've got a family and kids
you know I'll support them throughout
yeah I think often it's the case isn't
it when you grow up with not very much
um a lot of very successful people did
start with nothing even on the center
times rich list people like to think oh
you got lucky or are your parents
inherited you know left you a load of
money but actually it's the super
successful people often started with
very little yeah I don't think others
can have the same drive so it's the same
as being an athlete when you're rich
it's very hard to have to drive
so it's I look at it the same way like
if you grew up with everything why did
you want to go out there and work hard
because you don't have to whereas when
you don't have it you've got one choice
you either carry on not having it or you
work hard and it's like second nature so
for me personally my mum's always worked
hard so why wouldn't I work hard now how
important do you think mindset is to
this game because there's of course
there's a lot of technical skills that
you need to understand and know we've
talked about planning permission and
valuations and negotiations but how
important do you think having the right
mindset is in this business I think
definitely it's a people business if you
haven't got the right mindset you don't
stick to it you don't see things through
and you stop halfway no one's ever going
to invest with you the infidel's going
wrong or going right if you see it
through to the end ensure everyone's
abreast of all the details yeah you're
always going to succeed in the end not
every deal is going to make you a
millionaire but you know along the way
you're going to learn lessons that are
going to help you later on what's been
your worst property deal
I think it's one of the flips definitely
both flips we've done to earn more cash
so then buy more hmos and both of them
turned into disasters for different
reasons but he didn't kill the deal they
just created another learning tell me
about it Carlos was the first one in
Sheffield we took on a three-bed swim
State at the hotel so the hotel comes
subsequently by doing that flip so
everything works well
but um was up there we ripped it all out
gave it to the Builder and said right
let's see in couple of weeks we're back
after a few weeks everything was ripped
out looked good started putting it back
together you get the usual this doesn't
feel quite right so we were up every
week started having the proper look and
then basically things were getting done
quite quickly because he was cutting
Corners so you saw the floor was a down
carpets down every sort and you've gone
from building site to almost finished in
about two weeks so the alarm Bells were
on on the last visit we made before we
put a company so we went up there all
for the flying Freeholder we knew we put
an ensuite above and there's no drainage
pipes below me so I was like I've got a
definite problem here we went in went
straight to the ensuite running water
went to the back of the toilet pulled
the fitting off there's no pipes on the
floor so he's got everything running but
he's got no drainage now so the minute
we'd sold it yeah the flooded would have
had major problems off you know
hopefully with the fan that before we
sold it but we've had major problems
which we did anyway so I ended up
spending about 10 000 ripping back his
work and and doing good and making it
right damn but probably profit was doing
the job so still my profit yeah still my
25 Grand on that deal yeah I think it's
because we only take deals on where we
make sure the numbers were safe yeah
that we can actually afford for it to go
wrong yeah whereas when if the deal was
Mega tired like really we just wouldn't
get involved because hey there wouldn't
be enough profit
and um beef it did go wrong then you
haven't got a backup plan so there's
always contingency yeah what what else
do you look for in a deal is it do you
literally just buy based on the numbers
or is there anything else that you look
for in a deal the property doesn't
matter as long as it's got four walls on
the concrete base yeah that's it because
everything we do we rip it out back to
Brick generally and you can see the sky
from the front door on all the big stuff
we try to replace everything we can you
know so we don't get no comebacks we
don't get no issues maintenance is less
so it's pretty much just a numbers game
definitely because the location is
important yeah because that results in
the numbers that does result in numbers
however if the property is slightly out
of town so it's gonna be less desirable
well we'll lower the rents a slightly
and then we'll become desirable again
yeah we're just changes the numbers yeah
so every property will always rent no
matter where it is yeah it just depends
on what number how are you making
profits still with interest rates being
so high how because a lot of buy to let
landlords are struggling because they're
saying the rent's 800 the mortgage
payments was 400 but now now it's 800
I'm making nothing but you're still
making pretty damn good cash flow his
size and scale if we add a load of four
bed hmos we wouldn't be making much
money at all but because we've got a 14
bed 16 bed the underpins everything else
yeah yeah that's making enough money on
its own we don't need the other stuff
yeah so the stuff that isn't making as
much as it should it's still making
profit even our smallest four beds
making profit but obviously it's not as
much as it was two years ago but what
about if you if you've just got a two
two up two down buy to let with a family
in there then you're going to be very
hard-pressed all depends because we've
got the one in Blackburn the one we
first started with our mortgage is still
only 137 on that is that because you
fixed it though or is that no because
that's been refix since so yeah come up
from renewal so it went up because he
was only paying 87 quid a month right
yeah so it did go up but we get 550 for
that yeah but yes if you've got
definitely think if the house is worth a
lot of money and then the rent isn't
relative so down south you definitely in
trouble so it's about it's about buying
right isn't it if you're just an amateur
landlord or an accidental landlord that
just lives in the house and then you
move on and say oh I'll rent it and then
interest rates go up it probably doesn't
stack up but if you buy right so
presumably when you buy you're looking
at two factors you're looking at number
one can I push the value up by 25 yeah
so I can refinance and pull my money out
but number two what's the cash flow
going to be and is it going to pass the
stress test is it going to make me good
cash flow and those are the two sets of
formulas I imagine you're looking at
yeah they're the big things if you've
got a big buy to let you've got to leave
a big chunk of money in it and our game
isn't leaving money hanging around yeah
even our own money we get it out and get
it working if we've got money sitting in
the bank we'll lend it out to other
people the other investors and make it
work in the meantime so we never have
big pots of money sitting in the
accounts if we've got a couple of
hundred grand sitting there free we'll
lend it out to someone
you know get our Returns on it and when
our deal is ready to go we'll call it
back in time talk to me about debt
because a lot of people go to school and
learn never be in debt that's really bad
you are you know doing pretty well just
shy of a million pounds in equity you've
also got two million pounds worth of
debt how do you feel about that being in
2 million pounds worth of debt I've got
another million pounds worth of debt
with my own personal houses so he
doesn't bother so three million pounds
worth of debt yeah doesn't bother you no
how come it's what makes me more money
you know I'm leveraging from it without
that we would have a couple of buy
toilets so we need to use debt right you
know debt is the creator of the wealth
it's good there as well so I think
people just need to learn the difference
so if that was all all on finance cars
yes it wouldn't be a wise choice however
the revenue it earns covers the debt
you've seen it covers it by 50 so why
would we ever be worried about having
two million in debt do you plan to pay
the debt off at some point no no
what will happen then ultimately you'll
just die old men with lots of debt know
that my children will take my half and
and carry it on or they'll sell it off
with all these children ultimately
there'll be a group decision at the time
yeah but right now we plan to keep the
company long term
and it will you know carry on past us
talk to me about your boxing plans as
well now because I know you've you've
injured your wrist didn't you put it or
your hand pretty bad yeah so I had a
life change an accident on a glass bar
so sliced all the arteries all the
tendons and I got told never used my
hand again so thankfully that's all
healed now but yeah definitely probably
in the near future I did try about six
months ago to get back into it again and
I started going to the spa and I love
every minute of it but ultimately I just
didn't have the time with traveling to
Sheffield to be able to make all the
classes so I was sorry I was doing two
privates a week and then I was doing the
sparring on Fridays but when you're
traveling up to Sheffield and staying
there and you can't make it as soon as
you miss like for me it's definitely if
I'm not consistent then I don't want to
do it so I'm either all in or all out
but definitely with how the portfolio
has gone now I'll probably give it one
another shot at it because I've actually
got the time because there isn't a lot
of money in the kickboxing scene at all
so unless you make it to like one of the
best in the world now there's only just
started becoming what you could actually
live on before that you'd always have to
have a job or do a lot of PT and just to
get by yeah whereas because I don't need
that I don't need to fight for the money
anymore
then I've got the ability to pay for the
training and even if I don't get paid
just fine because I love it yeah I think
it was you said that it's hard to become
a world champion fighter when you've got
a lot of money you're proving that maybe
to be true you know now you've got a lot
of money it's like what do I need to
fight for I need to step in the ring for
I know you've got plans as well to set
up a boxing charity to help give back
and I don't know if you want to talk a
little bit about that yeah I mean I've
originally got my England coaching the
badges now for the local gym so we help
the kids Mondays and Saturdays tomorrow
either in the long run they're supposed
to do developments to have good causes
one of those is to open up boxing gyms
that are self-funding from the
properties above that are rented out so
the gyms don't need the money so that
you can keep organically opening more
gyms across the country to be able for
all kids to be able to come on box for
free they might have to pay to come to
the lessons but they'll be put back into
the the charitable good you know shows
and everything else that's exactly doing
yeah and I respect it man I think it's
it's really important what would your
final words of advice be to someone
watching this maybe he wants to get
started in property wants to follow in
the footsteps of what you've done wants
to you know start taking advantage of
the buyer's market that we're in right
now what advice would you give probably
have two be willing to do what others
aren't yeah
and also don't listen to others so when
we first started and we've done the
first buy to let and it was earning 550
people like I don't waste time don't
bother and it's only now the portfolios
are over 3 million that you get the
answers oh aren't you so lucky it's all
right for you don't have to now go to
work yeah but they wasn't there during
the years of hard work yeah I love that
also a training's key Training and
coaching get a mentor yeah and get
dragged forwards you might have the the
want to do it the motivation but if you
go in the wrong direction you're not
going up you're going sideways yeah no I
appreciate that and I'll tell you what
as well like you guys when you met me
you're already doing pretty pretty okay
you were learning as you were kind of
going but I think it makes so much sense
to learn from other people's mistakes
rather than trying to figure out
everything on your own and it's been a
real pleasure to work with you guys I'm
super impressed with what you've done
and I appreciate you coming on the show
and sharing some super golden nuggets
with people I look forward to seeing
your continued progression thank you
very much thanks very much cheers
cheers
[Music]